oh you've got to be kidding me  yeah  this is 476 barbary right yeah i'm  renting this place no i booked it a  month ago are you sure you have the  right place yeah who am i supposed to do  why don't you come inside and we'll call  these idiots  [Music]  why don't you just crash here oh no  i don't know if you got a great look at  this neighborhood  but i don't think you should be out  there by yourself  it's dry and there's a lock on the door  by the way i'm keith  tess  you take the bedroom and i'll sleep out  here on the couch  oh god  [Music]  keith  [Music]  [Music]  keith  this process might seem overwhelming  [Music]  but with a little practice  it can soon become  a pleasurable experience  this is perfectly natural  [Music]  you